everyone I'm David Griffin now Michael
Medina we were bringing this week's
review of arrow season 2 episode 18
Deathstroke bring it taking it up a
notch little bit last week from the
birds of prey again the ladies a little
time to shine love the ladies got
lovelies let's go so to do you gotta get
lazy something more interesting to do
and this week we got it on the form of
Deathstroke we got destro got a lot man
do banette still didn't get their
ultimate showdown that's probably gonna
happen the finale that what about five
six more up five celebrated at least
three more breaks throughout the season
so this could be you know my not get
this till sep tember no no um but this
episode's great destro started off let's
see where should we go to begin yeah
much stuff let's go maybe well I don't
wanna call to weaker part maybe the less
interesting part of this episode maybe
that's about the island flashbacks
against episode was awesome not sure I
say this this is a great episode but the
island stuff you know wasn't as
intricate even though it was it just you
have the same important to some other
weeks yeah I felt like everything of
importance was really happened in
present day right yeah i wanted i want
suffered it for the first time in a
while I wanted more present day in less
island absolutely absolutely because I
mean all that really set up was the
whole like you know a little swap
between Oliver and Hendrick but my
favorite part was when we finally see
Deathstroke kind of go lose it there in
a flashback when you start seeing shadow
right she's kind of like telling him
what to say yeah he is he is crazy yeah
it's crazy so I'm sure a lot of you are
interested in talking about I'm she was
gonna be theories galore it already has
been my girl summer glau has probably
come back to the show well talk about
her again now summers I was here um so
she's gonna play a big role in yet it
looks like i'm super gonna see her
probably every episode till the other
help i'd imagine what seemed like this
episode again and i loved it as well
yeah i thought that this is a good
episode up for the remaining episodes
five six episodes left and whatnot and
yeah she was she was goodness yeah you
know what i mean it was kind of like you
know good things come to those who wait
i guess right right you know um got to
see her now I hear you're kidding come
all the theories of course she is a
character from the comic book but so is
well Laurel maybe should be Black Canary
if we're going by comic book Lord yeah
you know this is DC you know Marvel they
like comic books mix things up nothing
is ever the same it's TV we're gonna mix
things up a little so she did this whole
sins of the father
reference with Oliver whole like you
should know who i am i'm surprised to
know why I'm the whole since the father
now does that mean that her father is
Deathstroke or is her father Oliver's
father he's on her half-sister which
would be weird because of other no
encounter yeah dad so I mean there's a
lot of different ways I could go yeah I
know like you'd mention it's true I mean
she seems like she would be a little too
old to be deaths Rebecca's daughter yeah
exactly but I mean old woman yeah yeah
absolutely but nonetheless I thought
that scene was interesting you know like
in the scene when they kind of reveals
herself all because this thing was
really all about the action see ya this
whole entire episode really it's all
about like the fight choreography which
I thought was great top notches and I
think they do a really good job week in
week out but this was just like really
like fight heavy and they did a
phenomenal job with that but I think
summer vowed to some gymnastics and
stuff anyway she's pretty like limber in
that way so I mean it was cool to see
her fight how much her how many of her
stunts that she did it was cool see her
fight when Oliver stormed the yeah the
warehouse trying to find say there's a
lot of good moments in here so you seen
summer glau back was great let's not
forget I mean there still is the whole
like you know Talia al Ghul can't forget
about that yeah is she telling a
possibility mean I will needs to come
back are we gonna see nice ax before the
end of the season I hope we see her
again oh and so much to go on episodes
all over the place haha Roy oh yeah I
was gonna say is young he he's going
rogue I guess I mean you know we finally
get to see a little bit of him training
with this bow and arrow or whatever and
that is what it is but you know we see
him kind of just like fall off the deep
end yeah in this episode and and you
know justifiably so with the Thea being
kidnapped and everybody just starts to
kind of losing it but Roy especially
with the mirakuru and everything kind of
you know flowing through his veins
attacks poor diggle diggle just trying
to sitio suit looking good i'll try to
hurt anybody english is not trying to do
much yeah Diggle just one saw this just
lay back I mean is why i gotta pick up
for dead ago but the question is you
know this is looking ahead there's
what's gonna happen with Roy we see him
driving for those young you know watch
the TV live watch on the CW network
wherever you watch it around the world
and when the trailer looks like Roy's on
an operating table possibly maybe he's
going somewhere to get this out of him
because he's in field he's furious
control I think this episode confirms
he's going to be more going towards
arsenal
absolutely instead of red arrow because
he had too many issues the ugly give me
a comeback and that's the thing I can't
see his character wanting to get rid of
the mirakuru anything I'd see him like
embracing it like maybe wanting a more
of it what I mean right but one of the
things I really liked about this episode
was just how Deathstroke really just
screws with Oliver it's not the way you
think no there's no torture no but
anybody up no punch anybody yeah he's
like the Cerebral Assassin right he just
good attacks you know his sister
everything his loved ones which he said
he would do yeah you know not the way we
thought about maybe try to kill people
he's not exactly you know he hasn't done
anything no I mean he's walked in he
said Oliver is arrow boob job done you
dropped a migraine he's done an episode
yeah done i mean but i really liked and
this is one of the things like i know
you know with his buddy Tommy died on
season one that was one of those moments
you know every superhero has to have you
know that tragedy and everything but I
always felt that there's still more
because we have to like I said before
remember that this is still early in his
career as arrow so we still good morning
Island we haven't seen absolutely oh
absolutely so the fact that like he's
really getting attack now in a way that
he himself even with all the training
everything he's been through on the
island he has no defense for he doesn't
know how to combat this because
Deathstroke or Slade keeps beating him
at every single angle and I love seeing
him just completely just like hands in
the air like I have no idea right he's
just doing subtle things he just yet
goes to laurels house and says hey by
the way Oliver is arrow and that's it
that walks away like I'm not gonna hurt
you I'm not gonna like poison you that's
it um and then you know we can't forget
about Moira her you know mayoral race
which some of you think is a little
ridiculous I agree i'm one of them but i
don't mind it when at least we get to
seek out Kevin Kevin Alejandro Alejandro
as brother blood yeah cuz I see him back
he's a really good character I lately I
can see that he really is just a pawn Oh
as like you promised me I would be merry
just kind of whining to desktop because
I promised you nothing you get what I
mean destro put him in his place pretty
much he's playing everybody right you
can see now that switch from not seeing
that um summer Glaus character is you
know more desktops right-hand woman app
say as opposed to Kevin Ollie hondro
she's like what he didn't tell you like
she knows everything is
white yeah I can't wait to see what her
reveal of course I'm sure there's gonna
be a lot of theories in the comments um
listen what else destro has an army yeah
buildings are me yeah henchman you know
well they did say they want to try to
replicate the mirakuru yeah you know so
my guess is obviously is gonna try to
build this you know super soldier army
and using um you know summer glau to
take over yeah of course it's all about
just like Batman it's like Christopher
Nolan shows all about the applied
science isn't it I mean if you want to
own a company make sure you get control
that's appliances so now they can start
manufacturing the mirakuru on a larger
scale so that's also something that's
going on later yeah I'm wondering too if
we're gonna get a chance to see cyrus so
you know see um Solomon Grundy again
yeah it's all a little like you know
stuff got in his face knows all you know
mess in the ass so I feel like it's some
point we got to see him at imagine he's
gotta tie into this as well right I mean
there's just so much good on this
episode I mean let's take a Thea like
what's gonna happen to Thea now I mean
she's emotionally a wreck yeah you know
and that's it I mean what's her name
what's his name broke up with her yeah
all you know Oh laid says you know he's
got a secret to tell her which you know
we thought it was gonna be his identity
exactly exactly kind of flipped it on us
late us as well right you know but I
know I like that like she's completely
broken down you know what I mean and
like that whole family at this point it
was wreck even down and we're who's now
winning in the polls which is funny also
Oliver and more is really cheap kind of
got back together absolutely to now be
broken by you know Deathstroke Slade's
just you know manipulation of the family
swimming there's so many good things
this has really been a great season a
couple week episode we can actually 20
episode season you're gonna have some
weak things you know force you know we
also have laurels dad you know now
arrested for helping this vigil I always
forget about the the cuddle one cop in
the whole sub 0 point the worktop I got
the one reporter a guy does the news and
he was a moderator during the whole day
you know that like one report gotta keep
it small small budget for the dub but
you know what i will say like i like i
like her dad you know he's kind of its
unintentionally like comic relief for me
right i'm just a cat yeah i'm just is
actually but i like them though so i'm
actually i'm still am intrigued
you know and I'd like to see again not a
lot of Laurel fans out there but i'd
like to see how she's gonna play in this
because now she knows about Oliver and
in the trailer for next week or a couple
weeks from now you see her kind of like
a quick glimpse of her like looking at a
wall she's looking at some stuff maybe
she's finally trying to like pee some
puzzle together and figure out like how
was I idiot is this true is he lying is
this true is Oliver the arrow so number
one she looks darkness in you can't you
know that let it out it's all that
ominous up I think she's gonna go a
little dark side someone actually said
she's gonna be dark side of the get
maybes a little bit extreme I don't
think this Smallville did dark side is
vastly good I don't think we're gonna
see dark side exercise an awesome
character camera pointing that out but
thank you for mentioning dark side so
many good things to come we have to wait
sadly this is network television this is
not HBO we'd have to wait another two
weeks now another break folks and
they're finishing strong yeah five
straight I believe until episode 23 I
think the next episodes called man
behind the mask and I know yes yeah I
mean mast in hoods going on so I think
it's gonna be great another great
episode this week I want to know what
you thought of course is always stuff
that Mike and I are gonna miss kids like
what everything is too much stuff to
talk about let us know your theories
about everything who do you think summer
Glaus character is who's her daddy let
us know it was your dad don't find us at
think you're calm most of this YouTube
page here I think you're a pro be sure
to subscribe like you know to go ahead
and now it helps out a lot we're also on
Twitter can talk to michael dennis or
myself about all of our theories on
arrow and what we like other CW shows
like we watching the hundred the
Tomorrow People any of those shows we're
at think hero i'm at griffin de nom at
mr. Michael Alexis also have a Facebook
page facebook.com slash think your fans
be sure your social media spread the
word all great things arrow we've got to
wait two weeks let's get the
conversations going in the comments
we'll talk about it for the next two
weeks yeah we'll see you see in a few
weeks
you